mafia three releases later this week but  you can take a peek at some of the games  challenges right now I'm Tony and fair  warning this gamespot news update may  contain some spoilers mafia threes  achievement / trophy list has been  revealed thanks to web site  xboxachievements.com pleating the story  or side objectives there are also a  handful of goofy achievements that  include feeding someone to an alligator  or being attacked by one yourself you  can check out the full list over at  gamespot but again be wary of spoilers  mafia three launches on ps4 and xbox one  and pc this friday october 7th if you  want to check out the list of  achievements you might as well also take  a look at the recommended pc specs for  more on the Mafia series as a whole you  can watch the first episode of our  reviving mafia series and for all the  most important video game news you're  already in the right place